thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the description can get a free trial
of skillshare's premium membership
do you ever wonder what it might take to
make a fish mad
not just like a little irritated or
cranky but fully leaping out of the
water mad
like maybe you've done that thing you
shouldn't be doing where you tap your
fingers impatiently at the glass of an
aquarium just to get a bit of a rise out
of its residence
but they just glide on by like you don't
even matter
you're just a creature on the other side
of the glass more provoked by a fish
than it is by you
but let us suppose you wake up tomorrow
as kafka might say
from uneasy dreams
transformed in your bed into a monstrous
vermin instead of the soft malleable
casing of your skin
you are now armored with a rigid
exoskeleton made of chitin that you will
periodically shed and regrow
your body is now an oval with four pairs
of legs attached to the middle thoracic
region and what does your head look like
it looks weird almost a bit like a butt
right except that structure at one end
of you is neither head nor butt it is
for males the testes and for the females
it is the spermathiki a place to store
sperm
this is your actual head much cuter if
you can call a head equipped with
suction cups and a needle cute but it is
a head similar to your streamlined body
that is built for one purpose because
you
are a fish laos and you are about to
provoke a fish
[Music]
now despite what the name suggests you
are not actually a laos you aren't even
an insect you are one of more than 100
freshwater crustacean species called
argulas
while you and your kind are found
throughout the world some of your
relatives likely got their start long
ago in asia they spread around the world
as the trade of carp and goldfish spread
not only the fish but their closest
friends as well
well perhaps friends is not the right
word
parasite that one fits better
of course the name doesn't matter to you
nor does your historical background why
track some origin that's ancient
compared to your lifespan when you
probably don't even remember your own
origins the mucus-coated egg laid in a
white mass
perhaps the weather was warm and you
spent only a few days amongst the other
eggs or maybe it was colder and you
waited weeks
and then when you hatched you had many
siblings anywhere from tens to hundreds
of them
but you've gone your separate ways now
in search of your next meal and your
next home two things that are for you
the same thing and if you find them you
have the chance to live to the ripe old
age of 60 days but if your search turns
up empty well then survival becomes
impossible
and that means the situation is urgent
but you do have a bit of time several
days potentially up to two weeks to swim
through the water and find the right
fish
fortunately you are not particularly
picky sure you have some preferences who
doesn't but at the end of the day a meal
is a meal and a fish is a fish
sometimes if you can't find a fish
you'll even make do with a frog to get
there first though you have to swim
paddling with your legs and catapulting
yourself from predators using lobes that
attach to your belly to launch yourself
away but when the opportunity or fish
presents itself the main appendages at
work are these suction cups or suckers
that you keep stuck to your target and
should you need to move the suckers on
their own are movable stalks meaning
that you can direct them independently
to scurry across your meal
once you have suctioned yourself
appropriately it's time to feed your
head comes equipped with a retractable
stylet that thin tube poking out like a
parasitic unicorn's horn
through that style it will travel whole
blood cells ready to feed you
this is a content moment for you a fish
louse needs only one fish in its whole
lifetime to sustain itself and while
this may not be the way everyone would
choose to live their life
who can argue with being well fed
the fish however takes notice
as you take up residence on its skin and
start feeding on it oh boy does the fish
take notice and it will try to shake you
it will scratch its flank against
whatever objects are around whether
that's a plant or a stone it will leap
into the air it might even jump onto the
concrete of a garden pond risking
predators and death as it tries to get
you off its back and out of its skin
perhaps it wouldn't have made such a
foolhardy decision under normal
circumstances but in the fish's defense
you have managed to get under its skin
just enough poking away with your stylet
and proboscis and possibly even
secreting toxins and digestive enzymes
that feed you and irritate the fish
and no one is quite themselves when
they're irritated
but you
well you will just go on unaware surely
of the damage you have caused of the
response you have provoked because after
all to you it wasn't damage it wasn't
meant to provoke it was just one
creature in search of food
through whatever means were available to
it
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and we would like to
also say thank you again to skillshare
for supporting this video if you're
feeling like diving head first into some
fish now you should probably know how to
prepare it properly because you are not
actually a fish louse and skillshare can
help with that with courses like
simplifying raw fish chef ken oranger
will take you through a 40-minute
culinary class where he breaks down the
basics of preparing fish at home you'll
learn what to look for when buying fish
essential knife skills how to select
ingredients and finally how to put your
own creative twist on each dish
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore real
world projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives skillshare empowers
you to accomplish real growth it's
curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads to distract you
and they are always launching new
premium classes so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your creativity
takes you
and if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description you can get a free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
the names you're seeing on the screen
right now well they
are a bunch of fish louses no doubt
about that they all came on this journey
with us because they love to look at the
beautiful world of the micro all of
these wonderful organisms that we're
able to capture thanks to the hard work
of our master of microscopes james and
his really wonderful advanced equipment
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram or also
on tick tock and if you want to see more
from us there is always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you